Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In computer graphics, we use the term shading
to describe the process of calculating the
appearance of a material. This gives the heart
and soul of most graphical systems that visualize
something on our screen. Let the blue sphere
be the object to be shaded and the red patch
be the light source illuminating it.
The question is, in this configuration, how
should the blue sphere look in reality?
In order to obtain high-quality images, we
need to calculate how much of the red patch
is visible from the blue sphere. This describes
the object's relation to the light source.
It it close or is it nearby? Is it facing
the object or not? What shape is the light
source? These factors determine how much light
will arrive to the surface of the blue sphere.
This is what mathematicians like to call an
integration problem.
However, beyond this calculation we also have
to take into consideration the reflectance
of the material that the blue sphere is made
of. Whether we have a white wall surface or
an orange makes a great deal of difference
and throws a wrench in our already complex calculations.
The final shading is the product of this visibility
situation and the material properties of the
sphere. Needless to say that the mathematical
description of many materials can get extremely
complex, which makes our calculations really
time consuming.
In this piece of work, a technique is proposed
that can approximate these two factors in
real time.
The paper contains a very detailed demonstration
of the difference between this and the analytical
computations that give us the perfect results
but take extremely long. In short, this technique
is very closely matching the analytic results,
but it is doing it in real time. I really
don't know what to say. We're used to wait
for hours to obtain images like this, and
now, 15 milliseconds per frame. What a hefty
value proposition for a paper. Absolutely
spectacular.
Some of the results really remind me of topological
calculations. Topology is a subfield of mathematics
that studies what properties of different
shapes are preserved when these shapes are
undergoing deformations. It's super useful
because, for instance, if we can prove that
light behaves in some way when the light source
has the shape of a disk, then if we're interested
in other shapes, topology can help us determine
whether all these enormous books full of theorems
on other shapes are going to apply to this
shape or not. It may be that we don't need
to invent anything and can just use this vast
existing knowledge base.
Some of the authors of this paper work at
Unity, which means that we can expect these
awesome results to appear in the video games
of the future.
Some code and demos are also available on
their website which I've linked in the description
box, make sure to check them out!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!